GRASSLEY AND CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN ARE ALL AHEAD.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
DON'T YOU LOVE IT WHEN ARROGANT
ECO
EC
ECO MANIACS ARE HOISTED?
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY AND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE
NOW KNOW THE PAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
INVESTIGATING ANDREW McCABE NOW
AFTER AN OBAMA APPOINTED IG MADE
A CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
AND POMPOUS CARDINAL COMEY IS
NOW BEING INVESTIGATED FOR
LEAKING CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
AND COMEY'S MEMOS WERE RELEASED
THIS WEEK AND THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO LAY OUT THE REAL REASON FOR
HIS FIRING.
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS COLLUDING
WITH THE RUSSIANS AND DONALD
TRUMP WAS LOOKING TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE.
WELL, UNFORTUNATELY, FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, THEY PROVED JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
AND THEY GO AGAINST VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING THAT COMEY HAS SAID
ABOUT TRUMP.
NOW BECAUSE HE DIDN'T TRUST THE
PRESIDENT, COMEY MADE NOTES OF
HIS PRESIDENTIAL MEETINGS.
THE MEMOS WERE WRITTEN
CONTEMPORANEOUS WITH THE
MEETINGS, ONE WITHIN FIVE
MINUTES OF THE MEETING.
CONTEMPORANEOUS NOTES CARRY
GREAT WEIGHT BECAUSE THEY'RE
MADE ALMOST IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THE EVENT WHEN THE MEMORY IS
FRESH.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY FOR JIM COMEY,
THEY DO NOT SUPPORT HIS
NARRATIVE.
IN FACT, THEY PROVE THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY PROVE ONE, THAT THE
PRESIDENT ENCOURAGED THE FBI
DIRECTOR TO INVESTIGATE THE
ISSUE OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
ANYONE ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA.
NUMBER TWO, THE PRESIDENT
ENCOURAGED THE FBI DIRECTOR TO
INVESTIGATE THE STEELE DOSSIER.
NUMBER THREE, THE PRESIDENT
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT HIS
ADMINISTRATION WAS FREE OF
LEAKS.
AND HERE'S THE RUB, THE MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT BY COMEY WAS
A SET-UP TO ALLOW CNN TO GO
FORWARD WITH A NEGATIVE STORY
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND TO
CREATE THE ILLUSION OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
COMEY HIMSELF ADMITS THE
PRESIDENT CNN WANTS TO GO
FORWARD WITH A STORY BECAUSE
SOME LEAKER GAVE THEM THE
DOSSIER.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE A NEWS
HOOK.
SO THE MEETING FOR THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE DOSSIER
WOULD BE THE HOOK, AND FOUR DAYS
LATER, CNN HAD THE STORY THAT
COMEY TOLD THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
THAT SALACIOUS DOSSIER AND COMEY
HIMSELF WAS THE ONE WHO CREATED
THE HOOK.
BUT FOLKS, IT GETS EVEN BETTER.
JAMES CLAPPER, THE MAN I TOLD
YOU LAST WEEK THAT JIM COMEY
SAID HE ADMIRES MOST IN
GOVERNMENT, WHO WE ALREADY KNOW
IS A LIAR, BASED ON HIS WE DON'T
SPY ON AMERICANS, WELL, NOT
WITTINGLY AT LEAST.
CLAPPER TOLD COMEY TO MEET WITH
THE PRESIDENT TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
COMEY IS DUMB ENOUGH TO ADMIT IT
IN THE MEMO.
HE THEN SAYS -- THIS IS COMEY
SPEAKING, I THEN EXECUTED THE
SESSION EXACTLY AS I HAD
PLANNED.
I SAID THE RUSSIANS ALLEGEDLY
HAD THE TAPES INVOLVING HIM AND
PROSTITUTES IN MOSCOW SO THEY
COULD LEND CREDENCE TO THE HYPED
UP RUSSIA COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
TRUMP HOWEVER INTERJECTS SAYING
THERE WERE NEVER PROSTITUTES.
COMEY LIED AND SAID THE FBI IS
KEEPING A CLOSE HOLD ON THAT
DOSSIER SO THERE WOULD BE NO
EXCUSE FOR IT TO EXPOSE HIS
STORY.
SO LET ME MAKE IT REAL SIMPLE.
CLAPPER TELLS COMEY TO MEET WITH
THE PRESIDENT, TO ALERT HIM
ABOUT THE PROSTITUTES, WHICH IS
A PRETEXT TO CREATE A NEWS HOOK
SO THAT CNN CAN LEAK THE STORY
ABOUT THE PROSTITUTES.
BUT ONCE COMEY IS FIRED, HE
DECIDES HE'S GOING TO LEAK
INFORMATION TO GET TO THE NEW
YORK TIMES NOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS LOOKING
AT THAT LEAK OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
>> MY JUDGMENT WAS I NEEDED TO
GET THAT OUT INTO THE PUBLIC
SQUARE, AND SO I ASKED A FRIEND
OF MINE TO SHARE THE CONTENT OF
THE MEMO WITH A REPORTER, DIDN'T
DO IT MYSELF FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS, BUT I ASKED HIM TO
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT MIGHT
PROMPT THE APPOINTMENT OF A
SPECIAL COUNSEL, AND SO I ASKED
A CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE TO DO IT.
>> JIM, YOU'RE THE HEAD OF THE
FBI.
YOU TOLD THE PRESIDENT IN THAT
MEMO REPEATEDLY, YOUR MEMOS,
THAT THE PRESIDENT WASN'T UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
YOU GET FIRED.
NOW YOU NEED TO PUT THINGS IN
THE PUBLIC SQUARE TO GET A
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
WHY?
YOUR MEMO, THE FIRST ONE, WAS
ACTUALLY SENT TO THE FBI, TO
McCABE AND COMPANY, AND SINCE
THERE CLEARLY WASN'T ANYTHING
CRIMINAL IN THAT MEMO, THEN
WHAT'S WITH YOUR HOGWASH ABOUT
YOU NEED TO GET INFORMATION INTO
THE PUBLIC SQUARE TO GET A
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED.
JIM, IT'S SO OBVIOUS.
YOU'RE FIRED, AND YOU'RE MAD.
YOU'RE A LIAR AND YOU'RE A
LEAKER.
YOU'RE POMPOUS.
YOU'RE EGOTISTICAL AND
CONDESCENDING AND VIOLATE THE
VERY LAWS YOU ARE SWORN TO
UPHOLD BECAUSE YOU WANT TO MAKE
NEWS BECAUSE YOU WANT TO WRITE A
BOOK BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BE A
HERO AND BECAUSE YOU DON'T THINK
THE RULES APPLY TO YOU AND
BECAUSE YOU LIKE YOUR FRIEND
McCABE ACCORDING TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL DO IT FOR
PERSONAL GAIN.
NEWS FLASH, YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
RIGHT TO LEAK THAT INFORMATION.
ONCE YOU TOOK THOSE MEMOS OUT OF
THE BUILDING TO LEAK TO THE NEW
YORK TIMES, YOU, JAMES COMEY,
COMMITTED A CRIME.
YOU HAD NO RIGHT TO DO THAT.
THEY WERE NOT PERSONAL NOTES.
THEY WERE NOT MEMOS TO YOURSELF.
THEY WERE MEMOS TO OTHER FBI
AGENTS.
AND IF DONALD TRUMP NEEDED
INVESTIGATING, JIM, ANSWER ME
THIS, WHY DIDN'T YOU INVESTIGATE
HIM WHEN YOU WERE THE HIGHEST
RANKING LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
IN THE NATION?
WHY?
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS NEEDED,
AND IT WAS SECONDARY IN ANY
EVENT.
IT WAS PHONY.
YOU NEEDED TO MAKE YOURSELF THE
PROTAGONIST, AND NOW WE KNOW FOR
THOSE MEMOS AND YOUR ILLEGAL
LEAK TO THE NEW YORK TIMES,
ROBERT MUELLER WOULDN'T BE DOING
WHAT HE'S DOING AND THAT IS
TEARING AT THE FABRIC OF THIS
COUNTRY, AND AIN'T IT
BITTERSWEET IRONY, JIM, THAT
BOTH YOU AND McCABE ARE BEING
LOOKED AT FOR THE SAME THING
THAT HILLARY WAS LOOKED AT.
YOU ARE IN THE SAME BOAT AS SHE,
BUT YOU LET HER LOOSE BECAUSE
YOU SAID SHE DIDN'T INTEND TO
HAVE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON
HER SERVER.
BUT JIM, YOU HOISTED YOURSELF
WHEN YOU MADE IT CLEAR THAT YOU
INTENDED TO RELEASE THOSE
CLASSIFIED MEMOS SO THAT YOU
COULD GET EVEN WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
YOU ESTABLISHED THE INTENT THAT
YOU SAY WAS MISSING IN HILLARY'S
CASE.
JIM, THE FBI'S NOT PROUD OF YOU.
YOU'RE A FORMER FBI DIRECTOR OUT
THERE DISCUSSING MATTERS
PRESENTLY UNDER INVESTIGATION AS
A SPECIAL COUNSEL IS DOING THAT
VERY THING.
WHERE DO YOU COME OFF PUBLISHING
A BOOK ABOUT ISSUES UNDER
INVESTIGATION?
EVEN ADMITTING WHAT YOU LEAKED
WAS SECRET AND THEREFORE
CLASSIFIED.
BUT YOU PROTEST, I DON'T DO
SNEAKY THINGS.
I DON'T LEAK.
I DON'T MAKE WEASEL MOVES.
JIM, ARE YOU SCHIZO?
ON THE ONE HAND YOU LIE TO THE
PRESIDENT THAT YOU DON'T LEAK
AND THE WHOLE POINT OF THE MEMO
WAS TO LEAK IT AND NOW ON YOUR
BOOK TOUR YOU SAY IT IS TRUE,
I'M A LEAKER.
AND JIM, YOU'RE A POLITICAL
OPERATIVE TOO.
YOU WANTED HILARY CLINTON TO BE
PRESIDENT.
YOU EVEN CHANGED THE DEFINITION
OF THE LAW TO LET HER GET AWAY
WITH IT, AND YOU PLAYED ALONG
WITH LORETTA LYNCH SO SHE COULD
GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> DO YOU THINK WE WOULD BE A
LOT BETTER WITH HILARY CLINTON
AS PRESIDENT THAN DONALD TRUMP?
>> CERTAINLY GIVEN HER
COMMITMENT TO OUR TRADITIONS AND
OUR NORMS AND OUR VALUES AND THE
RULE OF LAW, YES.
>> HER COMMITMENT TO THE RULE OF
LAW?
JIM, YOU ALSO HAVE TO KEEP YOUR
FACTS STRAIGHT.
THE SAME DAY YOU SAID HILLARY
WOULD BE A BETTER PRESIDENT, YOU
SAY IT IS TOO HARD TO GO BACK IN
TIME AND ANSWER WHETHER SHE'D BE
A BETTER PRESIDENT WHEN ASKED A
FEW HOURS EARLIER.
JIM, DO YOUR ANSWERS DEPEND ON
THE TIME OF DAY OR ON
MEDICATION?
JIM, IT ISN'T WORKING.
YOU'RE TRYING TO LOOK LIKE AN
OBJECTIVE INDIVIDUAL, UNTIL YOU
AGAIN ADMIT THAT YOU'RE NOT.
>> I SEE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AS
NEAR AS I CAN TELL REFLECTS NOW
ENTIRELY DONALD TRUMP'S VALUES,
WHICH IS IT DOESN'T REFLECT
VALUES AT ALL.
IT'S TRANSACTIONAL.
IT IS EGO DRIVEN.
IT IS IN SERVICE TO HIS EGO.
>> SO SHE'D BE A BETTER
PRESIDENT, BUT JIM, YOU NEED TO
BE CAREFUL.
YOU NEED TO BE VERY VERY
CAREFUL.
YOU KNEW FROM THE GET GO THAT
YOU WERE GOING TO CUT HILLARY
LOOSE, AND YOU KNEW FROM YOUR
TIME IN THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
THAT YOU WOULD GO AFTER DONALD
TRUMP.
YOU DECEIVED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND AS A RESULT, YOU, THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI, ARE UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR LEAKING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
YOU COULD BE LOOKED AT FOR THEFT
OF GOVERNMENT PROPERTY,
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE YOURSELF,
AND A CLEAR ABUSE OF POWER.
AND IF I WERE A BETTING WOMAN,
I'D BET THAT YOUR FRIEND CLAPPER
IS ANOTHER ONE SOON TO BE UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
ALL AMERICANS IS THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO WATCH YOU FIGHT EACH
OTHER, ANDREW McCABE WHO SAYS
YOU TOLD HIM REPEATEDLY THAT IT
WAS OKAY TO LEAK TO THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL," AND LORETTA
LYNCH WHO YOU ACCUSED OF
PRESSURING YOU NOT TO CALL
HILLARY'S CASE AN INVESTIGATION.
SO NOW FOLKS THE WHOLE IDEA OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION WITH THE
DONALD TRUMP CAMPAIGN FADES INTO
OBSCURITY.
WE NOW KNOW AND WE NOW SEE THE
DEEP STATE DOING WHAT IT DOES
BEST, STATE ACTORS PROTECTING
EACH OTHER AND LIKE MINDED
MEMBERS OF THE SYSTEM.
BUT IF THERE'S ANY JUSTICE, AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
INDEPENDENTLY RUN, YOU'LL ALL BE
MADE ACCOUNTABLE.
AND FINALLY, JIM, YOU'VE DONE
MORE DAMAGE TO THE FBI AS AN
INSTITUTION THAN JAY EDGAR
HOOVER BECAUSE YOUR MISSION WAS
TO CHANGE THE COURSE OF AMERICAN
PRESIDENTIAL HISTORY.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU
HOOVER IS THAT HE WORE DRESSES
AND EVEN IF YOU WANTED TO, YOU
PROBABLY COULDN'T GET ONE TO FIT
YOU AT 6'8".
AND THAT'S MY OPEN.